Coming back to the user interface, the customizable UI that we've got here, we've got a default
interface that favors a large viewport.
We can also, all panels are dockable and collapsible, and so we can move those into the real estate
that we want to on the screen.
We can also make parameters more accessible by adding them to a favorites list.
So you can, on the top right hand here, you can dock the outliner and the details panel,
and then also on the content browser at the bottom, you can hit control and space to open
that.
So let's just jump in the editor and I'll show you the favorites and the docking.
I'm going to hit F10 and that puts everything to the side so you can see everything is docked.
I can hit F10 again on my keyboard if I want to bring everything back out, or I can select
the individual options here and the outliner will pop out and the details panel will pop
out.
It depends on how you want to work.
When we talk about the content drawer, I'm going to hold control and hit spacebar to
bring up my content drawer, and I can hit control and spacebar again to drop everything
down.
I generally work with everything out, so if I hit F10 again, I generally work with everything
popped out just because it's easy to visualize everything.
The content browser is a really nice thing to have that can pop down and drop out again
though, just because it saves a bit more real estate space.
Then also on the favorites panel that I was referring to in the PowerPoint, say I navigate
myself over to a chair and you can see that I have favorites here that is cast shadow.
So on any of the properties, we can actually add as a favorite.
So you can just right click any property and click add to favorites and then that will
favorite it up here.
So if I wanted to have the static mesh property as a favorite for example, I right click add
to favorites and it pops to the top there.
So I can still have all my properties down there.
It doesn't remove any properties from down here, but they will pop them up to the top
and you just want to make sure this toggle favorites button is there and you can just
essentially add any variables that you're constantly editing and if you find yourself
scrolling up and down to certain properties, just add them to your favorites list and they'll
appear at the top for easy editing.
It's probably also worth highlighting on the favorites panel here as well.
If I go to edit, editor preferences and I'll add editor preferences and I type in favorite.
There's also context menu, show favorite selection and also flatten favorite menus.
So if you wanted to flatten the favorite menus, for example, you could just tick that tick
box and that might be a useful setting for you to have.